Hello everyone.
Thank you for tuning into the lane focus
channel.
My name is Paul.
Today we're going to talk about a common
question related to language learning.
Can adults learn a second language the
same way that they learned their native
language as a kid in a lot of the
marketing surrounding different language
programs and the courses that you can
buy,
you'll often see that you'll see them
justify their methodology by saying this
is the way you learned as a kid or when
you were a kid,
you didn't need written materials,
you just listened and all that kind of
thing,
so I wanted to talk about that.
Is it,
is it actually possible and is it
practical to learn that way when you're
an adult?
So let's get into it.
First of all,
adults learn differently from infants
and toddlers.
It's been proven through studies that
there is definitely a critical age range
after which it becomes more difficult to
learn a language.
When you are an infant,
you are using both hemispheres of your
brain for language learning and that
process,
that way of learning usually lasts until
you're about two years old and then it
starts to change.
It starts to become localized in your
left brain and your right brain starts
to be deemphasized.
Now it doesn't happen immediately right
away,
but that process continues from about
age two until you reach puberty,
so around the time of puberty,
so after you reach puberty,
your language learning processes.
Now a very left brain process,
it's much more of an intentional.
It's much more of an intentional kind of
study rather than just an intuitive
absorption of information from your
environment.
So it definitely does become different.
Let me play devil's advocate for a
minute.
Let's just hypothetically say that yes,
we can learn the same way that we
learned as infants.
Is that practical?
Should we learn that way?
I would say that it's really impractical
for an adult to learn their second
language the same way they learn their
native language because adults just have
a very different lifestyle than little
kids or infants do.
When you're an infant,
you spend about a year just sitting
there listening to the language before
you actually say anything,
just absorbing the sounds.
You're internalizing the phonology
before you actually produce it.
As an adult,
do you have a year to sit around doing
that?
I know I don't.
I have too many things.
I want to study too many things I want
to do and experience to many other
languages I want to get to in the
future.
I don't have a year to just sit and
listen,
so unless you were an infant or maybe
unless you're retired or unemployed and
have nothing to do,
then I guess a year of just sitting and
listening is probably a waste of your
time.
Am I right about that?
Now,
also related to time is this kid spent
so much time in an immersive
environment,
10,
12 hours a day,
their whole waking life.
They are surrounded by that language.
When their kids at school,
at home,
in their environment,
on tv,
everything is in that language.
Now you probably have a job that's in
your native language.
You probably have a circle of friends
that speak your native language and your
family probably speaks your native
language,
so do you really have 10 to 12 hours a
day to be immersed in your second
language and even if you are in that
country,
even if you moved to a country where
that language is spoken,
do you really have a circle of native
speakers who are talking to you all the
time,
the same way that adults talk to babies
or toddlers all the time.
When you're a toddler,
people are trying to talk to you,
right?
They're trying to encourage you to speak
and they're trying to help raise you by
speaking to you,
but when you're an adult,
most people just don't really care that
much.
If you are going to learn their language
to support you,
but they're not going to sit there
intentionally talking to you all the
time just to give you an opportunity to
practice.
So you probably have like one hour a
day,
two hours a day,
three hours a day.
Whatever it is that you have to focus on
that language,
but you can't be immersed in it all day,
every day,
the same way that a child can,
so that means that you have to
strategize and use that time available
to you in the best way that you can.
So as adults we try to look for ways to
accelerate our learning and one of the
ways we do that is by cutting out things
that we really don't need to learn right
now.
So tell me this.
When you learn a second language as an
adult,
do you really care how to say ladybug or
how to say Choo Choo train,
or do you care what the sound is that a
bunny rabbit makes like boing,
boing,
whatever it is,
do you care about all the Onomatopoeia
that appear in comic books like Bam,
boom,
smash,
sap,
Pow Kaboom,
Kapow,
splat?
Do you care about all those sounds?
Do you really need to learn those words
in that language?
Probably not.
When you're an adult,
you need to cut out the things that are
not necessary and focus on what's most
relevant to your adult life and it's
probably not things that are relevant to
kids a lot of the time now,
this is partly a matter of efficient use
of time,
but it's also a matter of what kind of
language is appropriate to use as an
adult.
Now kids speak like kids and they
usually speak that way for years and
years and years until they become more
influenced by the literary language and
they start to speak more like adults who
can be taken seriously,
but you as an adult probably want to be
taken seriously fairly early on,
especially if you're using the language
for work or for business.
So you don't have 15 years to spend on
speaking like a kid before you learn to
speak more like an adult.
Right?
Yeah.
So like I looked at the earnings report
and stuff and it was really cool and
stuff,
but my boss was like,
that's really dumb.
As adults,
we're at some disadvantages when it
comes to learning a second language,
but we also have some advantages and one
of them is our ability to analyze what
our learning needs are and to focus our
attention on meeting those needs so you
can look at your goals for the language,
what situations you will use the
language in,
and then focus on what you need in order
to achieve those goals,
so that's your advantage.
You should use that advantage.
You don't have to spend years and years
building a base the way kids do in order
to achieve your goals.
Another thing that makes learning as an
adult difference is that your self
concept affects the way you learn.
When you're a little kid,
you are carefree.
You don't worry about anything.
You don't really have an ego yet.
You don't think about your relation to
the world and what's allowed and what's
not allowed and things you can do,
things you can't do.
You don't really have that concept yet.
You just do whatever the heck you want
and as an adult you can't be like that.
You have all of these layers of self
concept that have developed throughout
the years.
You've developed an ego,
you've developed a sense of your
relation to other people into the world
and you think,
I can do these things.
I can't do these things if I do this
thing,
people will react a certain way.
If I do this thing,
people will react differently,
so that causes a lot of mental blocks
towards learning,
especially when it comes to languages
for some reason.
If you think that you're not that smart
or if you think that you're not that
socially savvy so you can't communicate
with people,
you might self sabotage when practicing
or learning a language,
that kind of thing,
or you might self sabotage because you
think that it doesn't match your
environment.
Like if your friends are all into sports
and they're all into music and you're
into studying a language,
maybe you'll be a nerd or maybe you'll
be different than them.
That kind of thing.
You start to be conscious of that sort
of thing.
As an adult or as little kids aren't
conscious of that.
They don't give a shit.
They just do whatever they want and it's
all about them.
So in order to learn the way a kid
learns,
you kind of have to get back into that
childlike headspace and forget about the
world and just focus on yourself and
it's hard for adults to do that.
I mean in some ways,
maybe we can learn from the way kids
learn,
but at the same time it's quite
difficult.
That doesn't really fit into the way we
live and you would have to remove a lot
of layers of your self concept in order
to do that and that would take some
effort.
That's kind of a separate mission from
here.
A language learning mission,
so it's much more practical in the short
term as adults to set up a very
intentional program of learning that can
motivate you through some of those
things that discourage you and actually
push you forward so that we can do that
through setting up a learning program
and thinking about our goals and
visualizing our goals and that kind of
thing to.
Because we're going to have those blocks
and we're going to have those times when
we hesitate.
Because of that self concept,
as adults,
we can get through that as kids.
You don't need to,
so we don't really need those
strategies.
So I think that's another big difference
between adult learners and child
learners,
especially when it comes to languages
for sure.
So the hype that you can learn a second
language,
the way that babies learn their native
language is exactly just that hype.
Do you think babies learn their native
language by listening to eight hours of
audio on a language CD?
Of course not.
So take it for what it is.
It's marketing hype.
You can see through.
It doesn't mean they're bad learning
materials,
but just don't buy into the marketing
hype.
Right.
This is Lang.
Focus on Paul.
Thank you for watching.
Have a good day.
Bye now.
This goes back to my first time visiting
Egypt in 1997.
I was in a backpack of resort called the
hub and I met a number of girls who were
there selling bracelets.
They were selling little trinkets,
souvenirs to tourists,
like me,
inner dialogue inside our head.
It's kind of a voice that's constantly
narrating our lives and commenting on
what's happening around us.